china eskaliert hat jetzt vor wenigen
minuten offiziell bestätigt ein riesiges
militärmanöver hat begonnen trainieren
für einen krieg um taiwan und dieses
manöver das ist nichts anderes als eine
massive kriegsdrohung china will sich
taiwan einverleiben das alles passiert
wenige stunden nachdem die amerikanische
spitzenpolitikerin nancy pelosi an
taiwan zu besuch war und bestätigt hat
dass die usa taiwan voll zur seite
stehen werden im ernstfall und jetzt
jetzt rot chinas diktator sie die welt
in einen neuen krieg dort zu zehn bilder
die tatsächlich auch hier in deutschland
angst zu machen
[Musik]